actually i want to use this to launch
off something you were talking about
earlier pertaining to
the coveted vaccine passports oh yeah
and what you brought up something really
interesting that immediately was like
nah you can't be right by that so let me
let me do this first we got some some
some news from fox biden administration
will not require covid19 vaccine
passports
white house says genseki says there will
be no federal vaccinations database
now this is kind of to assuage the fears
of people who think the government's
going to mandate
everybody get a vaccine passport but
they've long said we can't do that we
won't do that
the private sector will do that which is
still interesting because i'm not sure
the private sector
can do that because of a lot of laws
that already exist nondiscrimination
laws the ada et cetera
but i bring this up because we're
talking now about libertarianism
authoritarianism and what the government
is or isn't allowed to do and what we
should
should support so we'll do a hard segue
i guess and just
because i want you to bring this up you
mentioned that the covered vaccine
passports are not legal
yeah because of so we have a right to
uh medical privacy just use the use the
fancy buzzword oh i i'm i'm a god i
gotta i gotta train you wanna build the
suspense build up the sense
all right so in 1973 the supreme court
determined that um we are entitled to
uh to medical privacy and this was a
seven to two ruling
roe v wade determined that we are
entitled to medical privacy so roe v
wade
in the vaccine passports contradict each
other what
yeah interesting i don't know that but
yes they in their ruling they said
yes you are your medical history is your
private yes
they use the 14th amendment and they
said you're you are
the government cannot compel your your
you to expose your medical history like
we can't control that we we can't you
you are entitled to
your medical history that's i've heard
the 14th amendment thing
but what would that stop a private
company i guess theoretically i guess
you could sue
because a private company has no right
to your medical history yeah denying you
a service based on medical history i
mean they have to
ada it's it's it's crazy because
they could they'd have to go through you
to get it so they couldn't like go
through your doctor
because that'd be you know violation of
hipaa laws if they went through your
doctor
um so they'd have to go through you so
it'd have to be up to you
to expose that but i feel like you could
bring a civil rights violation against
against them trying to make you expose
your medical rights to like buy milk
right there was a big thing with masks
where people started saying that they
had they were like they
put out these fake cards where it's like
i have a medical condition and
protected under the americans with
disabilities act and then they would go
and walk around and if someone just
stores like i'd wear a massive like no i
don't i have this card
okay sure look the card's not real but i
think the idea actually is
yeah it's like imagine if a store was
like you can't come in here because your
legs are broken
you know we don't want to risk the
lawsuit if you fall and get hurt
yep so they say the same thing well we
require you to be vaccinated my medical
history and what i can or can't do is
under your business
and that goes into the bigger question
of they've said
if you're pregnant don't get the vaccine
they said if you uh if you have
allergies
you got to wait and you know joe biden
recently announced he's upped the
timeline so that every adult can get the
vaccine by april 19th
but what if your doctor tells you for
this reason we don't think you should
my doctor told me i shouldn't why is
that because i have a blood condition
interesting so now you're now you're
going to go to a store and they're going
to say
you need a vaccine passport and then you
can say it's none of your business
what my doctor told me and why is none
of your business
and what's going to what do you do i'll
probably get kicked out
well that would be a violation of the
americans with disabilities act wouldn't
it
yeah i mean i think the americans with
disabilities act is very specific with
what they
consider a disability um like
like my my blood condition isn't
like i'm not sure what's on there so i
don't want to misquote it
but um i know i know i
i couldn't get disability or social
security or anything from what's the
matter with me
so i wonder if that is required because
if you're also immunocompromised
that should be taken into account as
well because i probably won't get it
because i am
yeah so look the ada adata.org says
the americans with disabilities act
became law in 1990. the ada is a civil
rights law prohibits discrimination
against individuals with disabilities in
all areas of public life including job
school
transportation public and private places
that are open to general public
the purpose of the law is to make sure
that people with disabilities have the
same rights and opportunities as
everyone else
the ada gives civil rights protections
to individuals with disabilities similar
to those
provided to individuals on the basis of
race color sex national origin age
religion
it guarantees equal opportunity for
individuals with disabilities in public
accommodation employment transportation
state local government services
and telecommunications so i wonder if
they would argue that
you know okay so actually it says in
2008 the ada was signed into law
and became effective on january 2009.
the i'm sorry yes so so
the the it's the americans of disability
amendments act
it made a number of significant changes
to the definition of disability
the change in the definition of
disability apply to all titles of the
ada
so i have to go through the all the
changes but i'm curious if
your doctor says i'm sorry because of
your condition
you are not able to get this vaccine she
said i wouldn't recommend it
you got to take your doctor's advice i
know yeah so for everybody listening if
your doctor says you should listen to
your doctor that says you should
listen to your doctor because i think
you know you don't want to be getting
advice from people on the internet
according to that what you just read it
didn't say anywhere in there that
um like a restaurant can refuse cannot
refuse service to someone because of a
disability it sounds like
that law doesn't protect it it does
public accommodation means restaurants
but it's a private accommodation
public accommodation means like a
service provided to the general public
so a restaurant is a public
accommodation because it's a store
because it's open to the public
interesting so basically a private
shop would be like members only you
can't come in public is a sign saying
open
so if you're you know so so if somebody
walks into your restaurant you can't
accuse them of trespassing
unless you warn them first if you have a
private if you have a closed
private membership only restaurant and
someone walks in it's trespassing
typically you still gotta warn people
it's trespassing no matter what but the
general idea is
if it says open you're allowing people
in it's a public accommodation but i
mean actually
it's more nuanced than that even a
private membership business can still be
considered a public accommodation
like if someone says i would like to
join and become a member and you say you
can't because your disability then they
can sue you and say you're denying them
a public accommodation
could it be like uh this is a covid
vaccine only
restaurant that's what i'm wondering i
really don't know
it depends on the definition of
disability so
i would i would imagine that means some
kind of medical condition and if you
have a medical condition that prohibits
you from getting the vaccine
this is why we want herd immunity
because some people can't get it
right like there was this viral this
viral uh tweet from this woman
she's taking a picture of herself
getting the vaccine she's 14 weeks
pregnant have you seen this yeah i don't
know if it's real so again take it take
it all the grain of salt
and i absolutely want to make sure i
preface a lot of these
stories you know don't take one story as
evidence of
widespread anything anecdote yeah talk
to your doctor
i do personally know a pregnant woman
who has gotten the vaccine
and she's fine i haven't heard anything
yes there you go she's fine and this in
this viral meme
a pregnant woman gets a vaccine and then
a few days later has a miscarriage
yeah and it could happen it could be
right honestly miscarriages
when they happen they usually were going
to happen anyway
yeah 14 weeks though you're out of the
first trimester
which is when 90 happen and then so i
mean it could have just been a
coincidence it could have been related
to the vaccine we don't know that
it it could have just been all ready to
happen well
there there were in in i think the uk
doctors said
if you are a pregnant woman wait if you
have food allergies
wait yep talk to your doctor first and
so right right then it's like what are
we going to do are we going to deny
someone access to
the buy milk and bread because your
doctor says no
i think that is a civil rights violation
yeah i think so too human rights
imagine if they were like you have to
weigh a certain amount to come into the
store
because we know that obesity is a
contributing like causes them large
large amounts of death every year so you
go to walmart and they're like oh
you're too heavy to come into this store
if someone has the flu like 70 or 80
percent of kovid
deaths were obese yeah yeah yeah large
number that's alarming
we're obese i mean and that's why i
think america is
having such an issue with this because
we're so fat
for fat guys i think so there's a lot of
a lot of
excess that's sad and such an important
part of this puzzle
if you look at like the mediterranean
they're not anywhere and people are like
well that's because they're social
distancing and wearing massively no
that's because they're not fat
i saw a meme where it was like two two
lines going to two different kiosks and
one line was like
shots and pills and the line was
saturated all these people were in the
other
changing lifestyle yeah yeah i saw that
can we talk about fats on here
yeah hold on this is interesting
disability is defined according to this
website as a physical or mental
impairment
that substantially limits one or more
major life activities
a record of such impairment or being
regarded as having such an impairment
that's interesting because the vaccine
passport is what would make it a
disability
if right now your actor's like here's
our advice to you and for your you know
you weren't advised because of your
blood condition you shouldn't get it
so that's not a disability but if they
then say everyone all these businesses
have to have vaccine passports all of a
sudden now it is restricting you from a
major
you know major access to you know
services and stuff like that
interesting yeah and then you'd be able
to get disability insurance because you
couldn't go to the store
i wonder how would that work you gotta
hire someone to do it for you yeah i
don't know i mean i don't
my blood condition i i don't create red
blood cells
so that's why i'm so pale and why i get
winded going up the stairs
but that's um that's that's mine and i
mean you can't really see it you can't
really tell
um i don't want to you know carry a
passport around with it that
tells you know the stranger at the
supermarket what's the matter with me i
mean yeah
so this is the issue i take with the
libertarian party because
the government isn't going to be the one
starting the vaccine passports they're
they're
oh no we can't do it and they can't 14th
amendment great all these laws sure
but a private company can and then what
happens oh
thank heavens it's not the government
it's just it's just
walmart and amazon amazon you want to
buy something online it's like before a
delivery driver can come to your house
you must prove you're vaccinated
otherwise you're putting our drivers at
risk yep it's like well uh what am i
supposed to scan your qr code
enter your vaccine number and then
that's what private companies will do
well that's um that's a different so i
was talking earlier about libertarianism
how
it's a spectrum from anarchy to
constitutionalism
it's just a matter of how much
government is necessary and how much
government
is needed so um
so an anarchist view would just be like
nope we're just
you know they can do whatever they want
until the cows come home and there's
nothing we can do and you know
it's like oh for instance it's like
with what's going on social media oh
they're like create another
we're at a point where you need to
create another internet at this point
like you can't create
more um more social media because they
do that like parlor did that and what
happened
gone yeah you know so so we're at a
point where it's like well why didn't
you just create another internet and so
it's like okay maybe elon musk will get
on that i don't know but um
trump yeah trump trump could get on that
i mean there are
they could happen but you're going to be
bound to those rules too so
it's just a matter of like i like i said
i'm a menarchist
so i believe in justice and defense
that's that's really the limits of what
i believe
um to be the government's
um role for enforcing the constitution
um and so i would have to think at it
from that
perspective okay so are people like
where's justice gonna
like are people gonna be is there gonna
be an injustice here like if people are
not
being served if people can't is there an
injustice should the government
interfere because of this this human
rights injustice essentially if you
can't
have you know buy food or if you can't
like this is where it gets a little
sketchy
this is why i think the libertarian
party is pro-authoritarian yes they are
they're like the pawns of authoritarian
corporatist monopolist power
yes they are you have massive
multinational corporations and they're
going oh no the government is being mean
to our overlords
it's like what if you're actually for
libertarian
views the little l like true opposition
to authoritarianism
it doesn't matter if it's a corporation
or a government they're both
organizations just in different
capacities
the government is organized it's an
organized group of people who do a thing
a corporation is the same they have
structures they have a hierarchy they
have control
some companies are co-op some are
non-profits some governments are
democracy some are autocratic some
are i mean you had that guy what was
that name in
what was that guy's name in uruguay uh
jose mohica was that his name i'm not
sure he was like the president he lived
on a little farm he had a little car and
everyone loved him
i remember him yeah yeah so some
governments like that
government is not the same thing
everywhere and corporations aren't the
same thing everywhere
both can monopolize power and cause
problems i happen to lean against
you know i the reason communism and
socialism are bad is because it's a
bunch of people sitting down going i
have an idea
let's centralize all the power with one
group of people it's like that's a
that's a really bad idea
and then the problem i see with ancaps
and the libertarian party is they're
like
we should allow major corporations to
slowly accrue power so that a small
handful of individual elites control
everything and i'm like
what's the difference if your life is
dictated to
to you by someone else so we need to
restrict corporate power
and government power but you know we
don't we don't we don't get
the left to his typically being like the
corporations are bad and the right being
like government is bad
i'm like hey hey hey they're both bad
both
you guys are just both awful yeah yeah
they're both yeah well they both are
just awful well
if you look at what what these
corporations are
like we could have thousands and
thousands of competitors like you know
we could have
like everybody everybody out there
competing against each other and what
was i saying that there are what there's
there's like 10
10 businesses 10 corporations that just
own everything
they just own everything and what are
some perks that they have they have
um they they get billions in subsidies
billions
they they get special protections by the
government
um and then you know they buy up their
competition and
so there's language in the 14th
amendment
for government granted monopolies which
if you're given the money and you're
given the protections you're probably
granting their ability to exist
yes so if there's language against that
that those should not exist and that's
it's just not being enforced because
too many of these politicians are dirty
and they're
profiting off these corporations they're
in bed with the corporations so why are
they gonna
why were they gonna they're gonna get a
job once they once they get out of
office yeah it's a hard job man you're
fundraising non-stop lobbying
lobbyists maybe you don't get paid that
much money but then afterwards you get
this permanent access passed to capitol
hill
and all of a sudden now you can do
lobbying yep they can lobby these
government-granted
monopolies they're supposedly du jour
monopolies meaning by law
they'd be the government is like
instilling and but these
these aren't du jour monopolies these
aren't like twitter it's not a
government grant a monopoly even though
the government
subsidizes to be honest i don't know
what what they subsidize with twitter
but it's a de facto monopoly they are by
fact it's not by law they're not legally
monopolized they just have monopolized
the social sphere if the government
admits that they're
what'd you say du jour yeah du jour
monopoly then they have to abolish them
exactly so a lot of there's going to
exist de facto i hear a lot from
the laissez-faire capitalist or endcap
types and they'll say things like
tim you're not talking about a real
capitalism real capitalism you're
talking about corporatism and the
government's interference which creates
these monopoly monopolies
it's only because of special access and
special rules that the government
holds back the competition and props up
these big companies
and that's kind of true with section 230
for instance empowers those that are
massive to get away with whatever they
want and then destroy their opponents
but i'm like the idea that this isn't
real capitalism
just sounds like utopian to me it's not
real communism
sure that's not real capitalism i'm like
listen capitalism is infinitely better
than communism in a million different
ways
unfettered capitalism capitalism
outright will eventually
see power coalesce around a small
handful of people with or without
government regulation
we need to stifle that concentration of
power
i don't necessarily know how taxes is
one way
yeah the problem is it just powers the
government then you know what i mean and
the government just then grows and
becomes massive
and then they effectively just create a
revolving door between the massive
multinational corporations and
themselves
i mean you gotta elect people who are
gonna be like all right you're a
monopoly we need to call you that we
need to get rid of you
and also they're all puppets the
government's centralized too which is a
problem
exactly it's a monopoly the government
is a monopoly it's a monopoly on
violence and the ability to take money
from people we didn't have the
technology a bunch of bunch of
millionaires
imagine if netflix had a group of like
people with guns that they would show up
at your house and be like you have to
give
you have to sign up for netflix and
you're like i don't want to too bad yep
that's right we're here where your
innovation is yeah yeah
so if the government made a social media
site and then they were like you have to
sign up
well you're automatically signed up in
the social security in the uk you have
the tv licensing fee or whatever
everyone has to pay it unless you don't
have a computer or a tv
and it funds the bbc i guess we're in a
weird place where centralized government
it still kind of works well no i mean it
kind of works
but we're building tech that allows us
to decentralize the way we vote the way
we
interact with each other via television
internet video and things like that now
you only think that bro
well we're on the cusp of like a new
wave like putin and biden could get on a
youtube video chat tomorrow and have a
two-hour live stream together
sure that's not decentralization though
that's pure centralization he doesn't
putin doesn't have to fly to dc
we don't have to centralize anymore
that's that's semantics bro no
we can communicate one more right we're
talking about decentralization we're
talking about distributing
power between different nodes not one
point
biden and putin arguing is pure
centralization of power
and they're talking about each other
you're talking about spiritual or
psychologically
yeah putting all the power in an
individual yeah but actually
centralizing the fourth like washington
dc used to be the centralized point
of our power structure no longer we can
the government can function from
anywhere and probably does
it does that's why the people storming
the capital it's like what were you
thinking that was so stupid right we're
gonna enter this building and that's it
it's like
no that's not it it's the internet
exists what are you doing
yeah as those people so maybe maybe a
government i have a feeling government
will be built
that that facilitates the technology
and i don't i suppose it's up to the
people i think
the blockchain stuff is valuable i think
crypto is valuable
but if you think that these technologies
are decentralized i got a bridge to sell
you
you think that the us government just
sat back and watched bitcoin grow
exponentially and did not buy large
portions of
of the blockchain and set up servers all
over the place maybe they did maybe they
didn't okay
maybe maybe we can say the us
government's inept and that's possible
but i kind of feel like there's probably
confidential
stuff we don't know about we know china
was buying tons of bitcoin i'd be
willing to bet the u.s
tried to buy 51 to whatever network they
could
and they're constantly doing whatever
they can to maintain control of that
network
because if they got 51 percent then they
they own it
not decentralized sure well
we're not just relying on blockchain
there's other decentralized networks
like uh
interplanetary file system ipfs and new
ones that keep getting built
um and 51 is better than a hundred
percent
well no but why do you know what's your
fault all they need in order to control
100 of a network is 51
of the computers okay that's why i guess
why i said on the cusp we're not at a
point where
we have a decentralized system but you
know that is a light at the end of the
tunnel maybe or a light in the distance
decentralization require like
interstellar colonization
you know what what effectively allowed
us to break away from that from the
british empire
was probably was the distance 3000 miles
away it was very hard for them to
enforce anything
yeah and if we don't have a
decentralized system when we colonize
mars it will be solar war
so we have to for our survival solar war
i don't know if we do not want the first
solar war i don't know if we'll get to
that point
you know colonies on mars or wherever
else they're going to require a stream
of supplies
yeah yeah
they're not going to be able to survive
on their own without resources coming in
for some time
maybe in 50 years 200 years we'll have
biodomes and
we'll be taxing them and be like we send
you your supplies not anymore
and they throw all the space tea into
the into the
space space harbor on mars there's so
much they eject it into space
yes all that iron on this all that red
dust is iron oxide
yeah yeah there's a lot of iron on mars
they make martian swords with it
send them back to earth but then the
military's like we don't swordfight
anymore so they don't buy them and then
mars is like what are we supposed to do
and we need food
and so then we buy them anyway as like a
goodwill gesture to like make it seem
like we actually are buying something
when reality just like
arbitrarily making them work in exchange
for resources they declare independence
and they'll die
okay thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you